i've been diving since 1963.
i still get that thrill when i jump off
the boat into the water
i look at the shipwreck i think about
the history it represents it's a thrill
i really champion the cause of
protecting shipwrecks to let people
appreciate that a shipwreck is really in
the environment it's part of the
environment that need to be protected
and they ought to be accessible to the
public to appreciate them
my name is professor charles beaker i'm
a underwater archaeologist and a
specialist in marine protected areas
hold on to that sucker i got a chance to
go scuba diving and immediately fell in
love with it bought my first equipment
in 1966 by the 80s i got involved in
academics and then i realized that these
shipwrecks are really finite
they're a porthole to our past this is a
one-time event and it's a trapped
fragment of life for the people on board
a ship when the shipwreck goes down that
tells us about that time period
[Music]
we're at the underwater cultural
patrimony conservation laboratory this
is the national laboratory that is
involved with the conservation of the
artifacts that are brought up this is
just a fantastic object from the days of
columbus this is a sundial and you can
see the markings on the dial the roman
numerals
what i saw was numerous shipwrecks that
were heavily impacted by either hobby
divers or professional salvage
operations you go to the actual sites
and what you find there is relatively
little left
if everybody went out and picked up one
object there wouldn't be anything left
for us to see in the future
[Music]
these ship breaks really deserve being
protected i really spent my time trying
to look it away i make sure that another
30 years from now others will have a
chance to see these finite resources
i've been coming here to the dominican
republic to work with the government to
establish our first living museum site
we're showing that alternative to taking
these sites and turning them into a
resource that's recognized and would be
protected rather than a resource that's
going to be harvested and disappear are
you ready these sites are going to last
they will be around they're not going
away i'll be gone they'll still be here
and that's that's really a contribution
i'm very proud
[Music]